[Música]
y es el momento de revisar las noticias
más relevantes con las que amanecen los
medios internacionales y para esa tarea
la conversaciones con nuestra periodista
rosa pérez además de rózsa buen día para
usted buenos días ángel vamos a
conversar en nuestra conversación con
una noticia que llena los titulares de
los medios franceses y que causan
muchísima polémica el ministro del
interior francés anunció la disolución
de france révolté porque es una noticia
que ha causado tanto estruendo buenos
días es ángela pues si te parece
contextualizamos un poco esta noticia no
lo que sucedió ayer fue que el ministro
del interior francés real hermanan
anunció ante la asamblea nacional su
voluntad de llevar el procedimiento de
disolución de nand révolté al consejo de
ministros bien en primer lugar
especificar un poco de qué se tratan
aunque voltaire como vemos aquí allí a
quien lo califica como el medio de
liberación de un grupo antifascista pero
por ejemplo el medio de mont lo define
como un medio de comunicación de extrema
izquierda y ellos
se autoproclaman un medio de
comunicación local de la ciudad de
nantes en el oeste de francia e
independiente lo cierto es que a través
de sus conocidas y populares páginas en
redes sociales difunden muchos artículos
reportajes e informaciones alternativas
y muy frecuentemente con relación a la
violencia policial un caso pues concreto
sobre el que arrojaron mucha luz a los
acontecimientos fue respecto a la muerte
del joven steve maya en 2019 en este
caso el ministro de interior el
argumento que esgrime esa que llaman
recurrentemente a manifestar contra las
instituciones en francesas tienen
discursos contra las instituciones en
este caso particular en las viernes
llamaron a una manifestación que tenía
lugar en nantes
una manifestación antifascista que acabó
pues en disturbios y como comprenderás
angela pues estas palabras del ministro
de interior han desatado muchísima
polémica en redes sociales como en
medios de comunicación porque mucha
gente muchos periodistas también se han
solidarizado
con anand révolté por considerar este
anuncio un ataque contra la libertad de
prensa y de expresión vamos a ver si
acaba llegando a los tribunales este
caso un tema que tendremos que seguir
revisando más adelante rosa y le quiero
pedir ahora que hablemos de la que ha
sido una de nuestras principales
noticias de cubrimiento las últimas
semanas y es la tensión que existe entre
rusia y ucrania el día de hoy el medio
al yazira nos aporta una guía simple
sobre la crisis ucrania rusia 5 cosas
que debemos saber cuáles son bien pues
éstas a 5 preguntas que se hace al
yazira son porque hay conflicto en esta
concisa explicación al yazira se remonta
al imperio ruso a la unión soviética y a
su disolución a las protestas de 2014 a
la anexión rusa de crimea y en la mayor
escala a las tensiones entre rusia y la
otan por otro lugar siempre se pregunta
qué quiere rusia entre otras cosas pues
que ucrania no se una a la otan como
comentábamos
pregunta también así acabará uniendo
ucrania a la otan
gran interrogante y sobre todo las dos
grandes preguntas que se hacen medio
mundo pero sobre todo en la población
que vive en ucrania no se desatará una
guerra y qué pasa si rusia invadió
ucrania pues les invitamos a leer las
respuestas muy concisas que hace este
medio de comunicación y que más adelante
vamos a ampliar con nuestro invitado del
día después de conversar un poco de
europa ahora vamos a saltar hasta
américa latina'
el gobierno de boris chile en marcha el
país se le dedica su editorial a este
nuevo mandatario exacto este medio de
comunicación alaba la credibilidad de
bórico y el equilibrio que ha encontrado
entre la nueva izquierda y el
pragmatismo político de hecho en este
texto señala la presentación de su
ejecutivo ha mostrado que el mandatario
más joven en llegar a la moneda ha
apostado por el equilibrio la suma de
fuerzas y la lealtad a sus raíces y dice
que su gabinete ofrece una combinación
estimulante de políticas progresistas y
bing efectivos con el mejor pasado
democrático de chile rosa comenzamos
esta sección hablando de libertad de
prensa y vamos a terminar con lo mismo
una noticia dura el universal de méxico
dice que se une al luto en el país por
los periodistas asesinados
efectivamente y como símbolo de ello
tiene tanto en su versión digital como
en su versión impresa este lazo negro de
luto y en el texto en este comunicado
dice que se une a pedir el alto a la
violencia y exigir justicia por quienes
han sido callados en su labor
periodística puestos a le agradezco nos
deja mucha tarea para leer y que tenga
un feliz día ahora es el momento de ir
con nuestro invitado del día